Коли я приїхав у Німеччину,
у мене виникло таке враження,
що всі ресурси діаспори були зав'язані на те,
щоб зберегти максимально культуру
та ідентичність свого народу.
[Ukraїner
Країна ззовні]
[Бамберг,
Німеччина]
Матраци — це дефіцит, абсолютний дефіцит,
може більший, ніж лікарняні ліжка.
Тож я на кожний поклик,
якщо мені повідомлять, що є щось забрати,
[Богдан Пушкар
Священник]
я просто приїжджаю туди і забираю.
Можуть давати ліжка, можуть дати УЗД-апарати,
можуть дати рентген-апарати,
цілі операційні зали, операційні столи.
Як тільки почалася війна,
ми обладнали в Бахмуті лікарню,
там 350 ліжок, здається, 118 приїхало від нас.
В перших роках, там 2016-2018-й рік,
більшість гуманітарної допомоги йшла
на передову чи близько до передової —
в ті військові госпіталі, в ті лікарні там поблизу.
Ну а вже тепер й ідуть в райони України.
Я — українець, який народився в теперішній Польщі,
а точніше в Східній Прусії, в селі Генриково.
Мої батьки родом зі села Вербиця,
воно було розташоване над річкою Солокія.
В межах акції Вісла моїх дідів і батьків
вигнали з тих земель,
в вагонах для худоби переселили їх
в ті понімецькі землі, з яких вигнали німців.
Тоді там залишилися порожні місця,
і вони їх туди переселили.
Наш комплекс.
Тут був час, коли тут одночасно три фури вантажилося.
Одна сюди заїжджала, друга заїжджала в той спосіб,
а третя тут стояла одночасно.
Тут, бачите, храм.
Питання ідентичності ніколи не виникало:
хто я такий і що я тут роблю.
Коли мене в сучасній Україні пробують
назвати поляком, мені це образливо,
бо я ніколи поляком не був.
Я того польського громадянства ніколи не просив,
воно мені було нав'язане.
І місце, звідки походить мій рід,
воно було все заселене українцями.
Українців вигнали, але це не означає,
що я маю поміняти собі свою ідентичність
і національну приналежність.
Слава Ісусу! Василю, ти в кадр не хочеш попасти?
Я бусом 20 матраців привіз —
треба розвантажити, на складі.
[з телефону] Коли вам треба то розвантажити?
Зараз!
Після закінчення середньої школи
я рік працював на заводі,
який виробляє покришки для автомобілів,
тепер він належить концерну Мішлен.
Пізніше поступив у духовну семінарію в Любліні.
Василю!
Ходи, ходи!
В мене стався конфлікт
із тодішнім опікуном студентів богослов'я,
і мені дуже рекомендували,
щоб я шукав собі долі десь за кордоном.
Як почалася війна
і ми починали посилати наші транспорти,
то вони всі були спрямовані на схід, в зону АТО.
Ось ці печі, то вже залишки тільки.
Ми їх передавали в зону АТО для бліндажів,
для армії, щоб можна було обігріти.
Воно вже чавунне, воно набагато більше витримує.
Якщо клініка списала, скажімо,
партію ліжок, лікарняних ліжок.
Вони абсолютно придатні до подальшого вжитку.
Охочих отримати таку допомогу є дуже багато,
є от Румунія, є всі балканські країни.
Тут спрацьовує оперативність:
вам написали е-мейл чи подзвонили,
і ви маєте написати того ж дня
чи наступного дня відписати:
«Добре, я забираю! Тоді я, і тоді можу забрати».
Там тижнями чи місяцями ніхто не буде чекати,
щоб ми забрали ті речі.
Все, все!
Все! Шлюс, Параню, по коханню.
Ми звозили сюди ту медичну техніку,
ту всю гуманітарну допомогу.
Фура сюди заїжджала,
і наші волонтери збиралися на акцію,
і ми вантажили тут цілий день.
Це вже залишки:
те все має вміститися мені в бус і в прицеп,
я відвожу це в Україну і моя акція закінчується.
В мене є певні пріоритети...
Можна було б думати, що я як священник,
мав би насамперед допомагати церковним структурам.
В мене до цього великі претензії.
Я не хочу допомагати церкві,
щоб вона багатіла.
В мене на першому місці стоїть допомога армії,
тільки армії, бо не буде армії — не буде України.
Мені дуже боляче, коли українці зі зневагою
ставляться до всього українського.
А вона, то таке... А то ще...
Ну то тільки в Україні таке може бути...
Далеко в тих західних суспільствах
не все таке золоте, як воно світиться.
І так само суспільство має свої проблеми.
Ми їдемо забирати випічку,
яку нам передає одна з бамберзьких пекарень.
Ми цю акцію почали, як почалася корона
[пандемія COVID-19].
Багато з наших студентів втратили можливість підробітку.
Було питання виживання!
Ми з однієї сторони збирали для них кошти,
щоб було чим хоч оплатити гуртожиток чи якусь кімнату.
А з іншого боку звернулися до пекарні:
чи можуть вони віддавати нам свою випічку,
яка їм у кінці дня залишається не розпроданою.
І ось така екологічно чиста пекарня «Loscarn»
надала можливість нам тричі в тиждень
забирати їхню випічку.
Ми приїхали!
[говорить німецькою нерозбірливо]
[німецькою] Я маю ще дві коробки.
Вибачте за запізнення!
Я не вважаю себе асимільованим.
Я вважаю, що зберіг свою ідентичність.
В мене є нормальні, адекватні стосунки
з місцевими людьми, громадянами Німеччини.
Ми як українці повинні бути послами
української культури, українських інтересів.
В тій же Німеччині поважаючи закони,
культуру, звичаї цього народу —
це є коло, де ми живемо.
Я, будучи священником,
десять років працював на будівництві,
і, будучи священником,
мене там посилали десь на якусь зміну, щось робити,
і в двохтисячному році дали мені можливість
перейти тут на парафію в Бамберг.
Ідемо смажити шашлик, бо голодні будемо!
Так...
Це спеціальний парафіяльний шашлик, який уже традиційно
виготовляється з нагоди наших гуманітарних транспортів.
Тут доля змусила: треба було людей годувати —
значить треба було навчитися.
Якщо вкладеш трохи серця до того всього,
що робиш, то воно й вдається.
Ну, от як приходили волонтери,
щоб допомогти вантажити наші транспорти,
треба було приготувати.
Я тоді борщ варив 40-60 літрів, все з'їдали.
Я з перспективи часу вважаю,
що цей мій вибір був правильний.
Я, не будучи священником,
не міг би себе так реалізувати, як це роблю тепер.
Хоч я вже в житті багато чим займався
і багато чого доводилося робити,
але якраз це дає мені відчуття насиченості,
наснаги, виконання того покликання,
до чого я був покликаний, що я мав виконувати.
[читає молитву]
Зі страхом Божим і вірою приступіть.
[лунає церковний хор]
Хрест мого повернення в Україні
просунувся на вирішальний крок уперед.
Отже, мені вдалося минулого тижня
подати заяву на еміграцію в Україну,
і вона була прийнята.
Отже, план дії такий, що від першого вересня,
тут на пів ставки приходить
отець Андрій Химчук,
який має мене замінити пізніше на парафії.
Я напишу заяву, де буде зречення з усіх прав як паруха,
щоб отець Андрій міг вступити як повноцінний парух
і ваш пастир на моє місце.
За вашу всебічну підтримку я вам дуже вдячний!
І дай Боже, щоб такою, як моя отут громада,
яку я вважаю своєю, парафіяльну спільноту...
Я думаю...
Я б собі бажав, щоб вся Україна така стала дружня,
взаємно допомагала собі.
І надіємося, що ми дочекаємося того часу,
щоб це відбулося і в Україні.
У своїх всіх проєктах
я бачив себе як частинку одного цілого.
Отже, до мене хтось десь трудився.
Це є моя частинка, і після мене мають
прийти люди і ввійти в мою роботу.
Мені вдалося... Ну, я думаю, мені вдалося це зробити,
щоб не все було зав'язано тільки на священника.
Вдалося знайти якихось однодумців,
тих молодих людей,
які змогли виконувати роботу суспільну,
і політичну, і церковну, і соціальну.
Виконувати без того,
щоб треба їх там було штовхати до цього.
Це вони вже працюють і я дуже пишаюся!
Це моє найбільше надбання, я так вважаю.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Інтерв'юерка
Ольга Войтович]
[Режисери
Микола Носок, Василь Гошовський]
[Режисери монтажу
Ліза Літвіненко, Дмитро Бартош]
[Оператори
Алла Савчук, Павло Пашко, Сергій Коровайний]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Катерина Акварельна, Наталія Панченко]
[Асистентки продюсерки
Ксенія Ануфрієва, Євгенія Лисак]
[Субтитрувальник
Маршалок Михайло]
[Ukraїner]
[Ukrainisches Atelier für Kultur und Sport]
[Проєкт реалізовано за підтримки
Українського Культурного Фонду]